and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a bomb
tonight's review
while
oh my Chinese is a greatest movie I've
ever seen in my life
there's this kid who's a vampire only
nobody seems to know he's a vampire
he just has pale skin sunken in eyes and
never goes out during the daylight
already travels with other people who
have been skins like getting eyes and
never go out doing the daylight and all
the kids are like what is the kids so
scream it is one girl is like I don't
think he's Superman
so she starts doing some computer
research and the computer is like it's a
bit sucker a creature of the night
Nosferatu and the computers like do I
have to spell it out for you like
vampire and it goes like oh my god that
is so so you're the vampire start going
out any date that sounds like the
beginning of a joke isn't it everybody's
like you must keep my secret because no
one must know
and I'm like people from Egypt can tell
you're a vampire don't hide it very well
I'm against a shirt that says I am a
vampire bite me I'm the boy and girl I
like so weird girl is like I think I
told you but I'm just pretentious and a
vampire boy is like I would just stare
at you for some reason I find that very
attractive so first the grassland yo
your vampire I don't Nick Nick but the
guys like it's okay I'm a vegetarian
he says it's like eating tofu that's not
very scary you know they don't see
Dracula going around saying you're
coward I'm going to attack Whole Foods
so then he goes in the sunlight which I
guess doesn't kill it because the
vegetarian vampires they get more
vitamin D and they skin start shining
like diamonds and the girl is like boys
and girls are lucky if their boyfriend
gets him a diamond but my boyfriend is
covered in diamonds can I just wear you
up my finger but then the real evil
vampires come and they're like we want
to beat your girlfriend Eddie he's a
night way and they're like because oh so
we're gonna fire
trying to hide the way the girls better
the bad vampires are like ice no
pretentiousness she's that way so an
evil vampire bites the girl on her arm
and apparently he puts poison in her
body so he's a Cobra then tire killer
then I see one of those on GI Joe so the
good vampire has to suck the evil out of
her arm and mothers like you had to stop
sucking your suction too much and the
boy vampire is like that's nothing you
should see what she sucked at me oh
thank you girl in the vampire go to prom
and the girl is like turn me into a
vampire and the boy is like I can't
the girls like play and the boys like
because we're excited for sequels do it
then okay but then one of the evil
vampires is watching this but she
overheard that there were gonna be
sequels so she's like okay I'll just get
of this hurry so I like the vampires
even though they're kind of both push to
fight vampires I've ever seen but I want
to see as a vampire bum I would make a
good vampire buff except I wouldn't keep
blood I would drink alcohol and I
wouldn't fly I would just do drugs and I
wouldn't be interesting I would just be
incredibly repulsive just like a real
vampire who this is Jerry Busey change
I promise on my tofu women the children
tonight have stinky